the conference was fascinating um there
were a few takeaways i had
the first is that ai is advancing and
getting more powerful and practical
there was a company for example that was
an ai education company where
they monitor your eye movements and
facial movements to see if you get bored
during the lesson and then if you are
bored they like switch texts or do
something that like you know reactivates
you i should get one of those for our
conversations on this podcast what are
you saying bro when you get bored with
whatever that when i get laurier yeah or
vice versa it's like i don't need zach i
need ai's out hey zach you'll be like
hey hey hey all right i'm proud of it
so cow so ai
yeah there's an art to sleeping while
your teacher's not looking when you're
in you know middle school high school
right put your head down yeah apparently
and i can see through that [ __ ]
that sucks
[Music]
[Music]
this week on the podcast we're going to
talk about build back better uh is it
going to pass what does it mean if it
doesn't pass
we're also going to talk about this
incredible ai conference i attended last
week what the main takeaways were and
then we thought we'd end on some feel
good content recommendations for the
holidays just some holiday cheer really
[Music]
this week on forward zach and i look
into each other's eyes because there's a
new recording studio that has us facing
each other as opposed to side by side
longingly
[Laughter]
zack i never noticed how blue your eyes
were i never noticed still just now how
close these chairs were
together
whoever set the studio up wow
if you're watching on youtube we look a
lot cooler for love
call it an upgrade yes um so yes thank
you to the team that put this together
uh i think the studio looks great adam
and james superstars in texas
look at this investing in forward all
sorts of exciting stuff on the horizon
that's really no lie there there's a lot
of exciting stuff oh yeah on the horizon
the news is not that encouraging on
other fronts starting with
good old build back better so i have to
say when i talked to zack about this a
little while ago as in earlier today i
was like hey we're going to talk about
buildback better and zach's like
you mean that thing's not in the bag
it's not passing it's not in the bag
it is not in the bag it is not in the
bag so so wait can you remind everybody
in case they don't follow politics as
much you do what's build back better
supposed to be
build back better has been nicknamed the
social infrastructure plan it went from
3.5 trillion to 1.7 trillion
it passed the house
and now it's in the senate which means
it's really in the offices of joe
manchin because apparently the senate is
one person now
[Laughter]
so
right now the vast majority of democrats
are on board with some version of the
house bill yeah but it truly is that joe
manchin is looking it over and having
long conversations with joe biden about
what he will and won't sign off on the
senate has a lot of business to attend
to and
i will suggest to everyone that most
people believe that some version of this
bill will pass the question is when
and if it doesn't pass before the
holidays
then the child tax credit payment of 300
per child that's been helping
tens of millions of americans
over the last number of months
will be missed in january which i'm
going to suggest is going to be kind of
a big deal because if you've been
getting monthly payments of a certain
amount uh for the better part of a year
now
and then they don't happen in january i
think it's going to
be something that a lot of people notice
literally like millions of americans are
gonna look up and be like wait a minute
what like that i thought i was getting
that money and then they they they're
not gonna get it so the deadline
internally
that was put out uh by
uh the agency that's in charge of
administering the child tax credit
payments was that if this bill does not
pass by december 28 then they're going
to miss that payment so the cardinal sin
of politics is usually
and then why conservatives don't like
entitlement programs but it's when you
give people something and then take it
away so you don't usually like to do
that right so this
probably doesn't go well at least
politically i also am a little pissed
because of all the entitlements i like
this one because it's
direct cash yep you know there's not a
lot of bureaucracy that can get in the
way of that everyone agrees that the
child tax credit is the biggest public
policy achievement victory
of the last number of years it's lifted
millions of people out of poverty
millions of kids out of poverty
it's widely popular one of the problems
right now for the democrats in
particular is that most recipients of
the child tax credit don't understand
what it is and don't understand that the
democrats are behind it and one of the
things that i have tried to say is that
democrats are messing up by not
pounding their chests every month when
the payment goes out right like the 15th
of every month millions of checks go out
to families around the country that just
shows up in their accounts in most cases
joe biden every month should be having
an event in the white house
saying hey the child tax credit
alleviating poverty you know you love it
and every democratic official every
member of congress should be doing the
same thing there should be unison
on the 15th of every month families
around the country are rejoicing because
of this massive legislative
accomplishment you know what they are
crowing about which is in my opinion the
wrong move they're crowing about jobs
created in his first 12 months or so as
president which
i think is kind of a ridiculous argument
because we know that the economy went
from close to open so no one's like and
we're still down right and it's still
not great and jobs last night um and
then slight gas price reduction when
we're already super high um i think ben
shapiro tweeted something out where it
was like this is a perfect but i don't i
follow him on twitter but i'm not you
know been don't agree with everything
ben says i apparently have to clarify
that nowadays but
he's like there's a perfect like
democrat graph where they've like
stretched out the x-axis and take took
credit for like a small decrease in
slope um the price has gone down in the
last five minutes yeah like a little bit
um
but that like i agree with you it's like
the the ship is
i feel like there's a question for you
that
they're doing things i feel like they're
doing things right but there's so many
other things wrong that they're they're
not getting they can't get any credit
for the right stuff they're doing that
in many ways is truly awesome because
there's so many other things they're
trying to fix some like let's call it a
sinking ship or a burning building do
you agree with that or is it straight up
just like not good marketing i mean it's
both they should be taking more credit
for their actual accomplishment and it
should be crystal clear to the american
people
uh who delivered these child tax credit
payments
uh and also and this is the tough part
for democrats is who are you going to
blame if they miss this december 20th
deadline
it's hard to blame the republicans on
that one because it's legitimate it's
just like the democrats
trying to figure out how to get this
thing renewed
my sense of things is that it's going to
be difficult for democrats to complete
this bill
by year end the odds of
the country missing one of these
payments in january seems substantial
[Music]
okay real talk
how many of you listening to this
actually enjoy brushing your teeth
i
frankly can't stand it it's more of a
chore um or it was until
i got a quip electric toothbrush and i
want to tell you about them and i'm not
speaking for me my brother has been a
champion this forever before they were a
response on our podcast andrew's been a
champion this before they were a sponsor
our podcast i'm new to the game and i am
now a huge fan the quip electric
toothbrush is loved by over seven
million mouths as they say it's
basically got these it's a electric
toothbrush but it's got timed sonic
vibration with 30 second pulses to guide
what the dentist actually recommends
during a two-minute mouth clean it's
like lightweight it looks freaking cool
for adults for kids you got cool colors
it's got a travel cover so it's not a
lot of mess i used to use one of those
clunky electric toothbrushes and they
were awful to travel with this fits
perfectly and it's got this kind of
slick metal hue to it it's very very
cool and plus you can use their app and
track your brushing and get amazing
rewards like free refills and stuff if
you're doing it well it's pretty
high-end sleek tech awesome toothbrush
and it's not everything you need for a
complete mouth care routine right so you
can get their anti-cavity toothpaste
which i like and they give you floss
which i'm not great at but they give me
some which is awesome
in addition to this it delivers this to
your door every three months for like
five bucks so shipping is free you can
save money and skip the hustle and
bustle of in-store shopping or
forgetting that you need a new
toothbrush or a new toothpaste it all
comes to your door and it starts at just
25 so you won't be paying to the teeth
for better oral health so here's the
deal
once you go to get quip.com yang right
now you'll get your first refill free so
that's your first refill free at
getquip.com
yang that's
g-e-t-q-u-i-p-dot-com-slash-yang-quip
the good habits company check it out you
will not regret it
[Music]
so what's the holdup like what is
is it just joe manchin it's just joe
manchin and has he gone public with with
why he's what's hanging him up or he's
just loves this little spotlight moment
he's concerned i think is that and and
the economic data there were two data
points that came out that were not
positive number one was inflation very
high which everyone expected and number
two is that this 1.7 trillion dollar
bill will grow the deficit by 3 trillion
dollars over 10 years is what the
budget office projects right and the
democrats are saying no no no that's not
real some of these programs disappear
like that that's 3 trillion is not what
you should be concerned about but joe
manchin's been very very public saying
i'm very concerned about the deficit i'm
very concerned about inflation
and
he thinks that west virginia voters
are concerned about the same things and
will not be excited about this bill
passing so he is the the hold up um now
there are a lot of people in west
virginia frankly that are going to be
receiving these child tax credit
payments i mean like it's
extraordinarily popular there too right
um so
the question is
when does joe manchin decide to sign off
on what
so we talked last we talked a little bit
about inflation a couple weeks ago and i
asked you
you know what do you think the root
cause is anything you said a lot of it
is supply chain um
you know there's less bikes being made
and so
people your dollar is not the prices of
goods are going up because of supply
chain but i do think there's
bigger macro trends as well here and
it's i mean stimulus checks are probably
not helping but not the root cause like
do you
i don't think stimulus sex are causing
you but i don't think so either but well
i mean what's your what are your
thoughts on the inflation situation
right now i guess we'll start i i think
the economy's uh gotten a lot of
energy pumped into it because of some of
the measures the fed's taken and then
you have a constraint on supply and then
these things are intertwined i mean look
just like a gas our gas prices being
high because people have more money in
their pockets i would argue no would
argue that it's because they're a bunch
of freighters off the coast of
california that can't get to port
[Laughter]
and you know that that also influences
toys it influences a lot of other things
i think that that is the approximate
cause but it's also true that we're
we're pumping a lot of
uh liquidity into the system
and that some of that is making the
economy run hot
do you think it's an irresponsible
decision to pass a three trillion you
know something that increases the
deficit by x trillion dollars three
trillion dollars or so is it
irresponsible to pass a bill like that
when you're seeing
record inflation or
like what's the workaround or what's the
solution here in your eyes
to me it's about what you're using the
money for and who it's going to so if
you have this economic situation i do
not mind investing in airports bridges
and roads because guess what you should
have done that 10 20 years ago and you
know who the heck wants to be going over
a bridge where you're concerned it's
going to collapse or it actually does
collapse um so
that's it's a fine use of money i think
getting kids out of poverty is a fine
use of money i think are are there
things that you could look at this bill
and be like i'm not so sure about that
one not yet of course especially in a
bill this size um so
there are certain parts of this bill
that i am super excited about like the
child tax credit right and
um i i do think that democrats are
struggling to make a really affirmative
case for themselves and you could you
could also say look is it the democrats
fault that joe manchin is the 50th vote
and he is
not on board with this stuff it's like
it's hard to blame all yeah he's not
really a democrat right he's uh i mean
well and the democrats i i think
recognize that they're lucky to have joe
manchin because it's better than the
alternative right well because what are
the odds of there being a democratic
senator from west virginia not not high
yeah really low so then you you have so
that you have to take it yeah you take
it and then you know so that you know
that is it's a mismanaged expectation
there because it was the expect the
narrative was joe had a blue house and a
blue senate
technically true and
he actually doesn't he has a
blue house
and almost he's like a purple senate
he's a what do you call it an almost
blue baby blue
senate i don't know yeah
that's true and and joe manchin is
openly flirted with the idea of saying
look if you guys don't want me in your
party i'll leave and the devil is like
no no no
[Laughter]
let's not
be because the d
uh
label probably didn't help him there
yeah west virginia is not you know not
exactly buoying
joe i think west virginia generally
speaking is like a plus 18
uh republican state something like that
i um i do worry about i've always been
hesitant on big government spending
programs in general because um the
problems i've always seen is that
they're very tough to get rid of like i
was saying earlier and
it's not now that i'm worried about it's
not the implementation that's usually
pretty good like someone like smartly
and intelligently designs a system but
it's 20 years from now 30 years from now
where you now have
creatures in the system and
bloat and
excess spending and things that don't
work or changing with the times i mean
you name it right where you then end up
uh
cannabis system now where you can
literally say if we just gave people
cash it would be you know 50 times
cheaper right um
uh and you know you end up with that
stuff and because the government's not
graded a lot of things so the child tax
credit to me is a massive victory i i i
hope that
joe manchin decides to
renew this before year end and that they
don't miss a payment but if they do miss
a payment i am
curious as to what the level of popular
reaction will be
uh because this is something that i was
going to notice like if you're in one of
these
i think i i saw
that the numbers like 62 million
americans are in households that get
these
payments so
you know you'll have tens of millions of
americans being like hey what happened
to that thing yeah you know and
uh it may give rise to the conversation
that democrats should be having already
it's like like what is that payment like
how how did it get there who's behind it
because again i will affirm that
democrats have done a lousy job of
explaining and taking credit for
something that they should be calling
about every single month do you think
it's because it's a catch-all bill in
the sense that when obamacare was passed
or even trump's stuff trump was lower
taxes and frankly i guess repealing some
things he found a fight against
obamacare um but it was very it was a
little more laser focused if if possible
here you have a lot in that bucket well
if you ask democrats what they're
excited about in the
buildback better bill they're going to
say all these other things that frankly
are less direct than the child tax
credit that's right of course yeah so
you know if if you run around saying hey
guess what we're reducing the cost of
daycare
now am i for that i am for that you know
daycare is too expensive
but you know is that going to apply to
like every family no you know like are
there a lot of families that'll hear
that and be like there's nothing to do
with me
i mean like you should
be trying to take credit for the things
that and
so this is actually one of the main
problems of the democratic party right
now is that uh they're arguing for
things that they think you should care
about uh and then when
there's something you
do care about they'll be like oh you
know i'm not going to pay attention to
that because i'm not i'm going to tell
you what you should care about or like
here's what i care
about you caring about
like those slides
uh now again there are a lot of things
in this bill that i very much love
um
but
uh
it it seems like they have dropped the
ball generally on the child tax credit
messaging uh and we're gonna see if this
this thing passes by your end uh the
thing that most people are going to
notice if it does not pass by december
28th is going to be this missing payment
in january
and then the pressure will be on like do
they pass in january does the payment
happen
right they have an expectation
management problem and that i think that
cap's out of bag now it's they already
were expected to do something and we
haven't uh well you get the
infrastructure bill but now we've most
people thought that uh buildback better
was on its way to passage yeah yes
here we are so we will keep you posted
as always uh a couple days after
whenever the thursday after it happens
you will know first
[Music]
it's the holiday season which means it's
a great time for a lot of people but you
know what honestly it's also a really
depressing time for a lot of people i
don't know maybe our lives aren't like
the movies maybe we're thinking about
people that aren't with us but in any
case right now is a great time to take
charge of your mental health to get the
professional help that a lot of us know
that we've kind of needed for a little
while
don't put this on your friends and
family they have no idea what they're
talking about some of the times
instead you should use our sponsor
betterhelp.com
and there are professional therapists
who are trained and available to you
when you need them it's like mental
health
on call it's pretty amazing this is one
way that we can use the services of
today to actually improve our lives and
if you visit
our sponsor at betterhelp.com
yang you'll get 10 off your first month
join over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp h-e-l-p-com
yang happy holidays let's make him happy
for real
[Music]
we were traveling this week and we were
renting a car and
the people sitting at the car desk at
the hertz or where we budget where we
were
they looked um
i felt for them they looked bored they
did not look fulfilled in their job they
were lovely to us for sure um
but it it just
it hit me that that job's probably going
to get automated sooner rather than
later um
given that they didn't look like they
were using every second of their time
and all the incentives are going that
way and we haven't talked about
automation in a while so you just went
to a conference on this so tell us uh
anything cool you saw and then we'll
dive in a little deeper the conference
was fascinating um there were a few
takeaways i had
the first is that ai is advancing and
getting more powerful and practical
there was a company for example that was
an ai education company where
they monitor your eye movements and
facial movements to see if you get bored
during the lesson and then if you are
bored they like switch tax or do
something that like you know reactivates
you i should get one of those for our
conversations on this podcast what are
you saying
when you get bored with whatever that
when i get laurier yeah or vice versa
like i don't need zach
there's an art to sleeping when your
teacher's not looking when you're in you
know middle school high school right put
your head down yeah apparently and i can
see through that [ __ ] geez
that sucks uh and it's meant to help you
engage more yeah theoretically better
right um but it's getting better and
stronger and more practical so that
that's one takeaway another takeaway i
had was that its job replacement
capacity
is growing and that's hand in hand with
some of the things you're describing in
the labor market so we're in the midst
of a fairly nasty cycle which is you
look up and say hey you're short workers
well like then let's automate
the jobs that are there and then you
need fewer workers and you have fewer
workers i mean right now we're still
down last i checked about 4 million jobs
since pre-covered
and the labor force participation rate
in the united states right now is maybe
61.9 percent
something really low
uh if you look at the international
comparables i think we're tied with
ukraine or something along those lines
if you look at other
industrialized countries that you think
of as modern economies and peers they
are they're almost uniformly higher than
us
are they doing something better than we
are in this or we just have oh they're
yeah they are they're you know they're
like are they avoiding automation like
what that's kind of how i was going like
so
what's happened here in the us over the
last number of years is um you had our
labor force get driven up and up by
women showing up in the workforce
and then um after that advance then it's
been going down down down for the last
number of years and years and years a
lot of the people that are getting
pushed out of the workforce are men are
are non-college-educated men and by the
way that's driving a lot of political
and social
phenomena
ills i mean it's not
uh positive in most any of these
communities and and so then
uh you
have automation also that now is
speeding up
uh you have people who are dropping out
of the workforce right now for a variety
of reasons some of it's health related
some of it is meaning of life related i
mean this is a very very tough time and
so a lot of people are
taking a step back and if you have the
capacity to take a step back even for a
month or two
particularly by the way if you have a
job that you're
pretty confident you can get an
equivalent job at the drop of a hat you
know what i mean like if if i'm in like
i always go back to x yeah like let's
say i'm a server at a restaurant or i'm
a retail clerk um am i pretty confident
i can just show up to another store or
restaurant and get a job like that right
now yes yeah of course there help wanted
signs everywhere so it's like well if i
have the capacity to take you know four
weeks off or six weeks off and or do
something why don't i do that because i
know i can just swap back into that job
other countries
uh have
done a a better job of trying to find
fits between workers and employers there
are some countries that have very very
generous bridge and subsidy programs
where they say
look
you're losing your job because for
example of automation and this does
happen in some european countries like
what we're automating your job away
we're going to be moving heaven and
earth for a while to like find you a new
job we're going to subsidize this we're
going to do that we're going to like pay
for and they they actually execute
they know we do yeah better than we do
like here a politician goes to a mic and
says we're going to do this and then
just everyone forgets about it and then
you go back and nothing happened
but some of these countries actually are
uh taking workers and leading them by
the hand to like employers and being
like hey let's try and make this thing
work interesting um so
there are
there's some trends that are speeding up
in the u.s and ai is part of this i
talked to one company
that has a labor replacing robot that
costs approximately 55 000
and replaces one worker um working all
the time
so
never stops yeah so if you do the math
on that like that robot's going to pay
for itself within one year yeah maybe
less probably less because they're not
working working weekends and nights
right yeah
and so i think that
robot's going to sell a lot of units
and then when you know when you look up
and say hey where'd the jobs go i mean
people are going to go like well you
know no one wanted this job so we got
this robot
and and here it is so that was the the
second big takeaway i had um the third
was i got
reminded of some of the hazards around
uh ai leapfrogging humanity and being
unfettered in its impact and decision
making there was this russian
mathematician
you could tell he was [ __ ] brilliant
it's one of those things but he they
talk math in an accent i usually just
think you're smarter than you actually
yeah that's because i'm dumb this guy
was also a professor in a major
university and the rest of it so he was
talking about um there were some smart
conferences like really really uh
high-end so the types of conferences
andrew's getting invited to on ai are
pretty for but it's for what it's worth
they're pretty cool man yeah uh thanks
yeah
yeah you better be you're one of the one
of the bigger thought leaders on the
topic okay keep going yeah and yeah it's
like you were saying so it's also the
case that i turn down a lot of freaking
yeah yeah and you have something you get
a lot of them so when you decide to go
yeah
it's a good one because most of them i
just i'm just like hey no offense if
you've invited us to a conference we get
a lot it's not personal yeah sometimes
it's a little personal but
okay done so so this uh mathematician
said something that stuck with me even
though i kind of knew this stuff already
he was like hey if you have an ai
that let's say is like a little smarter
than a human
um maybe maybe it's genius level maybe
of like a human genius level ai
but then it can self-replicate itself
like a thousand or a million times over
and so then you have a million genius
level intellects working on something
simultaneously and it can actually line
itself up so that it's all able to to
conjoin
um so
you you reflect on that for a moment
you're like oh my gosh then you can
really
[Laughter]
it was like above average intelligence
yeah he's like he's like he doesn't even
need to be like you you don't need like
one like super genius level ai if you
have even like a fairly intelligent ai
that you can then replicate a thousand
or a million times over and because of
the way it's wired it can actually have
those
um
those units all working in tandem in
concert so that they're
speeding
each other up or speeding up the entire
process and then it really dawns on you
for a moment you're like oh wait a
minute this thing really
is going to
transform a lot of what we think of as
work
so this particular mathematician there
were a number of things that a lot of
smart people said at this conference but
they were like hey
right now the natural
state of affairs is going to lead the
rewards to end up being
held in the hands of a small number of
firms or individuals
and the level of public safeguards are
kind of lacking
and so we should be pursuing some kind
of manhattan project
government-led uh initiative to try and
keep ai from doing
negative things
um as it's getting stronger and more
powerful
and i heard this from a number of people
there and they were all correct and then
i thought to myself oh gosh like where
is our government on this
and our government is not exactly
you know uh
at the
vanguard of trying to figure out what's
happening in these labs
or in these firms
um so
that reminded me of some of the
large-scale issues that we're facing
another person spoke about how
there are a couple dozen countries that
already are investing in ai
weapon systems that
are going to naturally want to make
decisions as quickly as possible because
you have to consult a human it slows you
down
so
one of the proposals is for countries to
come together and adopt a treaty that
says hey
a human has to decide when to use lethal
force it's not just that an autonomous
system goes whoop you're in the wrong
place like you dead
that sort of thing um but he said that
the natural impulse for countries is
going to be for speed and efficiency and
not trying to have a human somewhere in
that length security guards like
guarding a border of some sort or a
drone or something like that where maybe
it's got some humanity
baked into its code but it's going to
shoot to kill
when it sees a warm body or whatever it
is right is that kind of what we're
talking about especially some of the
countries that are bootstrapping that
they're just like it kills anything that
moves right yeah and then you have
asymmetrical
non-country actors so there's an
international world order that right now
is not exactly humming you know you have
different factions
uh and then you have non-state actors
and
whatever protocol you come up with so
right now the countries can't even agree
on how to use ai right militarily and
then if you have non-state actors or
even terrorist organizations getting a
hold of some of these things then of
course
they're going to be no rules
so you you start reflecting on what this
is going to mean over time you're like
oh
my gosh
uh so so those were some of the things
that i took away and i will say that
this conference was very very positive
they were people that were trying to
solve these problems they were like look
let's come together and and
um get in front of this stuff
um and so i don't want to be
super pessimistic in part because
uh you know like it was a conference
around solutions
but a lot of very smart people were very
concerned about the natural trends and
we have been for a while um you ever
read i used to read this blog wait but
why
yeah yeah by tim urban and he's done he
is one on elon musk
a while ago was really good um but he
did another one on ai
and basically the school of thought at
least then i think it's still a case is
that um
so there's like
three forms of ai there's can do one
task better than a human being that's
like when we play the
computer in chess or we uh
play
you know someone uh
gps i guess giving you directions faster
or something like that one task though
then there's it can do every task it's
as smart as a human being and then
uh we haven't gotten there yet and the
third one is it's smarter than a human
being and in his uh the the school of
thought is that
we're at stage one right now we know
it's not an if but it's a when we'll get
to stage two when the computer is as
smart as human being
but we don't know we don't know when
that is but we do know that once we hit
two we'll essentially immediately hit
three
because as soon as as soon as it has the
capacity to improve itself then it could
improve itself to be smarter than us
yeah
and then infinite yeah yeah
exponentially so yeah and then the
analogy he used in this blog post is
that it'd be like um we will be like a
monkey looking at a skyscraper like well
no
it's a skyscraper or we'll know like
it's a big object
we'll know it's got shapes and forms and
maybe people going in and out and we can
see activities but we won't
fundamentally understand what that
skyscraper is
which is
terrifying i think an ai in general i
don't know it's like a next stage of
human evolution or evolution i guess
it's not human anymore
[Music]
is there anything uplifting from the
conference yes there was all right
here's the uplifting part so there was
this
professor
who was using ai
to help scientists and other disciplines
find a cure for cancer
and one of the truths about science
generally is that it's not terribly
interdisciplinary
where if you have
biology researchers do they understand
how to use the computational abilities
of ai to go through gene sequencing or
if you are chemist drug compounds
and so they're just starting to be able
to utilize some of these tools to their
potential
very very uplifting stuff around
reducing brain aging
because of
eventually our brains decay and for many
people it means alzheimer's which is a
freaking life destroyer and family
destroyer
and so they think that they might be
able to treat alzheimer's
using ai in part
cure cancer so there was some uplifting
research being done really
awesome and some
phenomenally talented people who were
running that i'm sure
there were also people with money there
so here was one of the dynamics is that
is that if you were doing this high-end
research maybe you come because maybe
someone there is just like hey i want to
write a ticket i want to yeah i'll cut
you a check
yeah
one of the sidebars and i
i had
derek thompson on the podcast
a few weeks ago he wrote an article in
the atlantic about the bottlenecks
around scientific research and now he's
digging in and writing a book on the
bottlenecks around scientific research
and i so i talked to some of the
scientists at this ai conference being
like hey
now you know i was reading about how
academics and scientists spend 25 to 40
of their time writing grant proposals
which by the way is a waste of time if
you're you know a high-end scientist
like you should just be actually doing
research and whatnot and and he said oh
yeah there are a bunch of problems
associated with the funding of
of science um where if you're a
scientist
you kind of know what the grantors are
going to like and most of the time it's
going to be building upon past research
that got a grant and so you wind up with
one it's super time consuming and two
you're going to be pursuing avenues that
people kind of are confident are
fruitful
if you are someone who is going down a
new road and by the way maybe you know
you don't have that much time or you
don't have like 10 prior grants and like
you know and and this massive
decades-long career in academia then you
won't get a grant
and so there's not a lot of risk-taking
in science but in these environments
sometimes this particular
um academic for example had received
over 10 million dollars in funding from
like a tech philanthropist who
recognized that this person was
maybe going to help cure
brain diseases and was like here's
here's some money right um and so that
there are some things going on like that
that are at the margins
uh one of the big questions is could you
actually get into the guts of for
example the nih grant process and
make it better speed it up in some way
there was another
initiative called fast grants that one
of the stripe
founders started just doling out mini
grants to scientific projects and just
to see if um
there might be something promising that
right now is getting overlooked i
instinctively love this stuff yeah um i
talked to my brother who's a professor
and said hey what percentage of the time
do you spend writing grants and he said
you know half 30 30 to 40.
uh and so so you've never written a
grant it's usually awful
it's like a questionnaire on a job
application oh it's it's a million times
worse than that like i i talked about
what i talked to my brother about so
here's my conversations with my brother
as an example
i'll be like hey man what's up and he'll
be like hey can't talk grant do 10 days
from now and i actually know exactly
what that means because
the the week to two weeks before the
grant he's
um pulling near all-nighters he's trying
to pull together all this research from
different uh people and teams
imagine
something that's like thesis level
but it's not just yours you have to
bring in
partners
and co-authors and then you submit this
mega proposal to dnih and oh by the way
people's careers depend upon what score
they give it so that there's like a a
freak out so if my brother says to me i
have a grand proposal within 10 days
that means i will not talk to you until
after this grant proposal is done and
then after the grant proposal's in there
is even like a recuperation day because
of all of the grinding like if you look
back to you know when we were in in
college or whatnot and you remember you
know like finals period and like that
then you'd die for a doubt and then yeah
so imagine doing that as like an adult
for decades like that's the process that
right now we have uh built for
our best researchers by the way like
these are people that are actually doing
the best stuff because if you're not
doing the best stuff you're not going to
get a great to begin with like but we're
gonna put people who are already proven
themselves through these crazy
um processes because
uh and oh by the way and this is the
other bottleneck my brother my brother
described to me
was that
who evaluates this crazy grant proposal
that he writes it has to be
peer-reviewed so there's like a limited
number of world-class researchers who
can evaluate the proposal to be able to
say whether or not it makes sense
so so this is a bottleneck because there
aren't like you know an unlimited number
of things
and so one of the things i said was like
why don't we just [ __ ] pay the
reviewers and he's like right now
reviewers don't get paid because it's a
privilege and you're furthering science
uh and and they don't want to taint it
with commercial motivations and i was
like what's tainting it with commercial
motivations like i'm not going to give
you a high score just because someone
freaking you know compensated me
at least i thought this was at least one
bottleneck um because if you're a
world-class scientist you're trying to
do your own research and then when they
hit you up to review someone else's
grant proposal it's not exactly the top
of your priority list i mean you might
do it because
uh you know you want to give back
um but there's a ton of stuff in
academia in particular that operates on
these soft incentives where you're not
getting paid it's like oh this is a
privilege
uh you know
it's it's like oh it's the publisher
parish thing it's like hey if you
are running these papers and you get
this prestige and then you know you get
to keep your job or get tenure or
whatever the thing is like there's this
entire
elaborate set of incentives it's highly
institutionalized so if you imagine
these uh innovative cutting edge
scientific research projects they're
probably not going to be included in the
conventional process much of the time
so this is where my head went on this is
that we just had a conversation on
joe biden and his administration
how they are
not
doing good enough job like selling their
work if you will
and
and we're like yeah you better do better
job selling it but here we are talking
about professors
and
they i guess the equivalent of them
selling their work is like trying to get
more money and selling it selling their
work and their ideas to others like
there's i guess my question to you is
like in most parts of
in any sort of i'm going to call
entrepreneurship or building anything
there's a certain level of building and
then selling what you're freaking
building right
um
and if you're an entrepreneur if you're
ceo like how often are you fundraising
if you're a nonprofit it's all the time
but if you're a ceo it's probably
probably 30 to 50 percent of your time
right by similar range maybe is it um
are are you saying i think you are maybe
that for
worlds like academia where you have like
that level of one commitment and
expertise and probably super brain that
we should get them off of that like
they've devoted their life to just
discovery like i don't know
why should it be different than some of
the other worlds you and i operate in
well heck man i mean uh as people who
run nonprofits when you're like always
fundraising you want to i hated it yeah
oh you know guess what also like you're
not doing the work during those times
yeah
you know like it's true like i mean i
went to conferences all the time as the
head of a non-profit and just trying to
be around people with uh grant writing
capacities it was a strange thing it's
like you'd go the other thing is you had
to be
um really
uh discreet like you can't go around
being like hey give me money hey give me
money or everyone be like oh who the
heck are you instead you're like yeah
you're like oh
um i love when you're building oh yeah
yeah
would love your guidance on how we can
improve our you know so there's like
this kabuki
now for
an academic it turns out there is a
marketplace for their research
and they're bound to it in various ways
so the main marketplace for the research
is uh the nih or whatever um agency is
funding a research but most of the most
of the stuff at least i've heard of in
the fields
that we're talking about is through the
nih and so if you get a grant from the
nih then they pay for your research
and the school they are associated with
get some of that grant money so if
you're at a level where you're getting
millions of dollars in grants from the
the nih
then any institutions like ooh like you
pay for yourself if you're an academic
and your grants run dry
uh then
if you're for example tenured then you
get to keep your job but you have to
teach classes
for
your salary
and then if you're teaching class you
don't have time to do research so this
is the thing that all these academics
are trying to avoid they're trying to be
like oh i have to get grants so i can do
more research
and oh by the way like not spend all my
time teaching classes right um that
that's not you know what what professors
are digging
for the most part now if uh now i talked
about this academic who's getting money
from a tech philanthropist
now that's highly highly unusual yeah
that there's not much of a private uh or
philanthropic market for academic
research most of them are just beholden
to
the grant writing and i'm assuming
that's because it's low roi right
if you're you're throwing 10 million
bucks at a
carrying cancer or xyz research project
your odds are probably not going to find
it right until
you know years and years and years later
millions and more dollars is that why
the
the market's low
it's only that there are superstar
academics who are doing research that is
interesting enough where if you're a
philanthropist you're going to throw
money at it yeah we used to at ubs it
was there were some but there was not a
huge appetite for this kind of crazy
risk research if that makes sense like i
would talk to professors decently often
they'd be like oh we've got a new way to
we think we can cure colon cancer
and i'm like i don't i don't know a
single donor it's like passion about
funding that right um like sometimes but
not a lot you know
so that this is something that i'm very
interested in is seeing if there's a
better way to fund scientific advances
so that we're seeing more
breakthroughs more medicines more
positive things yeah because
through my family i've i've seen the
current system
uh
being an academic it was kind of the
family business my dad was a professor
my grandfather was a professor yeah my
brother is a professor
i'm kind of the
you know in the black sheep for i'm the
educational rent of the letter yeah like
you know no phd phd yang
and
there was a brief period when i was in
college i thought like should i try and
be a professor but i was like ah it's
not for me like i you know right and
seeing my brother's
career as much as i admire and respect
all the stuff he he does i also think
like that it wouldn't have been a good
fit for me right if you're a wealthy
donor right you're worth 100 million
you're talking about people with 100
million dollars on up right because they
can easily write your five to 10 million
dollar checks and move the needle for
these places
the universities know who they are and
find them because they have massive
development teams and their job is to
really scour the world for rich people
and and get these checks so the
universities are doing that job for the
professors to get their cut if that
makes sense you know they're but when
the universities are are scouring these
donors they're getting they're getting
big money instead of just specific
project yeah yeah yeah they're not
they're funding they're getting their
own kitty right and they'll totally
they'll pitch it like oh we're curing
colon cancer we're kieran x we're doing
sometimes they'll be like hey there's a
professor you want to fund their
research but the most part is just going
to the university yeah let's do our
awesomeness and they get their handheld
they get by the party it's all the name
of the building whatever it is right
yeah um different model um
anyway
um
i want to ask you this quickly before we
shift to something a little more
positive although this is positive but
um
the world automation we never talk about
this when you run a president was that
um but you wrote about and now we're
seeing
epic effects of this and probably worse
than we imagined with mental health and
the deterioration deterioration of
mental health the united states of
america
i had this thought that i'm curious if
you've seen this in your research or who
had thoughts on it is do you think the
mental health deterioration
and the problems of mental health in the
united states are actually accelerating
automation because human beings if their
mental health is declining probably
become more painful to employ or deal
with
in the sense that or maybe they're not
they're maybe they're quitting their
jobs too yeah
memories and so imagine this will
we never talked about that as a an
accelerant of automation but i imagine
it would be well it's an accelerant of
people having unfilled jobs and then
you're going to look around and say okay
how do i how do i man this
retail
kiosk or counter how do i
make this restaurant more efficient or
whatever it happens to be yeah that's
happening for sure one of the the things
that
a lot of us can sense right now is that
there there is
uh a massive spike in people feeling
anxious depressed lonely
out of touch disconnected i saw a
documentary yang yang documentary
actually thank you ching
um
my yang gang diary uh you saw your own
documentary uh what are you saying yeah
but it was based in 2019
and you realize just how positive
times were relative to now like you just
see people walking around in 2019 i mean
you know it's like
there's a very very sharp difference
between 2021 and 2019 yeah
and
the the pain is accelerating all sorts
of terrible things uh people are
struggling very very fundamentally it's
one reason why i'm so passionate about
this child tax credit because
at a minimum we can take the
um
existential pressure off for millions of
families but yeah the mental health
crisis is worse than ever in my opinion
i think it's i miss these like little
interactions at work
you know well so this is something i
said to derek too
where
uh and i i have family members who are
in this boat where if you ask someone's
like hey do you want to go back to the
office like hell no i don't go back to
the office
um but then if you watch them over three
or six months like working from home
they become depressed and miserable yeah
now so if you were to choose i mean no
one wants friction no one's going to be
like yes sign me up for a commute sign
me up for my annoying boss sign me up
for
annoying corporate behavior for larry in
accounting who brings tuna fish in for
lunch every day no thank you right yeah
but then it turns out that the absence
of all of those
uh interactions you're talking about
like don't lead you to positive places
necessarily
um and that's playing out in
like hundreds of thousands probably
millions of households around the
country
[Music]
we are doing a lot of fun stuff normally
on this podcast we're talking about some
of the stuff we're working on you're
working on
um the only thing we really talk about
is forward party work which is going
great and there's there's movement there
but um
also
i want to throw out there too
humanityforward.com has been lobbying
for child tax credit they're really
doing great work too i am so proud of
both humanity forward and the forward
party like humanity forward is the
wholesome lobbyists for good stuff we
have some big uh
announcements on that front soon and
then a forward party super excited about
this unifying political movement to try
to create real choice
uh and um cure the dysfunction in our
democracy i had a very exciting meeting
about that
earlier today so there there is some
great stuff going on on both of those
fronts
yeah it's um so we have more coming up
which hopefully so there is there's more
optimism to come even you know um but
for starters so imagine it's thursday
you're listening this the 16th
hopefully many of you are starting to go
home for the holidays maybe this weekend
maybe you work from home a little bit
with the family so
i like we got a lot of good positive
feedback on content recommendations last
time so
andrew what are you watching
over the break
i i mentioned it last time but i'm going
to miss succession i just saw the season
finale i haven't watched it yet that's
on my list yeah so if people haven't
watched succession not some quality tv
i can talk about some of the stuff i
have not seen which is kind of hazardous
i was a huge matrix fan huge matrix fan
oh yeah and i think this matrix
resurrections movie is going to be good
it's coming out christmas eve there is
that uh don't look up movie on netflix
that you said looks hysterical uh by
adam mckay oh yeah leo and jennifer
lawrence and jennifer lawrence which
looks really good
and that's gonna be on netflix and i
love the big short he's a good director
yes i'm going to do something a little
bit
mixed uh and so that this might not be
useful
i read this fantasy book series called
the wheel of time years and years ago
when i was a kid yeah and they just came
out with a maybe 200 million dollar
version of it on amazon amazon prime
have you watched this i have not watched
it it's on my list it's not the top of
the list though should i put it on the
top list or you this is your plan to
watch well so i watched a few episodes
and
this is not a wholehearted recommend
okay um this is like you watch it and it
kind of
it gave me mixed feelings as someone who
kind of knew the characters and the the
book okay um
but it that there is like a
xena warrior princess vibe to it plus
just lots of blood
it's not like like it's just going along
and then every once in a while something
kind of gnarly happens you're like what
okay and then it reminded me too so i i
was watching this series
and i was reminded of the books and then
i looked up the author of the books and
he was a military veteran
and it gave me those kinds of vibes
where it's like the books seemed
very compelling when i was a kid because
there was like a grittiness and realism
to them
um so the my caveat on the series is
like it it's not giving me like escapist
good times you're not getting circa 2021
it's like it's kind of making me feel
like oh a little depressing and raw yeah
it's a little bit like but you know like
the the kind of grittiness you know it's
like it's not necessarily what i'm
looking for
my girlfriend doesn't like most of the
stuff i want to watch not that she
doesn't like the shows it's just that
she wants to watch something happier you
know
yeah it's funny because like succession
i mean it's it's gritty in the sense
that it feels true to human nature um so
you know but everyone and i've been
enjoying the heck out of that and
there's humor there at least you know
uh i saw a quiet place too on streaming
the other day
and that was a tight watch it was like
only in maybe an hour and 37 minutes and
i was
surprised by how crisp and enjoyable it
was it was a very very succinct
compact movie so here's all that i
watched king richard the other night you
would recommended that that's an
uplifting movie very well done um the i
didn't realize that the williams sisters
produced that which is uh
even cooler i'm big will smith fan um
what i'm excited to watch
i got three things excited what i'm
excited to watch and you guys can hold
me accountable if it's bad or good
foundation on apple tv if you have that
another expensive sci-fi series yeah
another one sounds similar not similar
to wheel of time but it's about um
frankly like restarting human
civilization so but i think it's a
little more uplifting than what that
sounds like um
apparently the sandra bullock movie
called the unforgivable that just came
out on netflix is very good um probably
watch that the new spider-man movie is
out but i think you have to watch it in
theaters or comes out over the holidays
but
that relation that relationship is
adorable one other
zendaya one other series that uh been
watching and enjoying a lot is a show
called genius uh that's now on hulu the
first season is about albert einstein
and i did not know most of this stuff
about einstein's life it was based on
the walter isaacson
biography and you're like wow this is
what was going on with einstein like at
the time and uh and so
that that's been a really good watch
it's done by i think either national
geographic or the bbc it's kind of got
that euro
vibe like you know kind of dignified
okay like i'm learning something jeffrey
rush uh plays einstein okay at a certain
time so the the talent level is very
high emily watson's in it that gives you
a sense of it emma watson no emily
watson who's like kind of the older
dignified british actress
so that there are some dignified brits
uh and so they're pretty good acting it
feels classy
i learned something there's a lot of
history history and context
genius and and they
they switch subjects every season so
season one's einstein got it and there's
a different one every time yeah um
here's i will say if you're gonna binge
a podcast that is not
forward obviously um
my brother got me down this rabbit hole
and it was worth it there's a podcast
called the murdoch murders it's murda
i think it's augh it's about a family in
south carolina that basically has run
this county
in south carolina for like 100 years and
there's like four random murders that
happen that you would never think you're
connected there's like a dui on a boat
and then there's a double homicide and
then there's a housekeeper like
caretaker that fell down the stairs and
there's another like attempted suicide
and there's a guy gets hit a hit and run
they're all different people and they
all get and they're all connected to the
same freaking dude and the way it's done
like she's a reporter she's reporting on
it in real time it is fascinating it's
the basically the trial of alec murdoch
or the case against alec murdoch and
it's wild and it catches you up to the
present because it's still going so i'm
a little pissed that i can't keep
binging but it's very good um i will say
adjective
um and she talks about this her voice is
not like uh
soothing i'd say i don't want people to
voice their voice but i will say like
don't come at me and be like i didn't
like her voice like that she addresses
that in the second episode but i think
she's super talented and does a really
good job diving in and it's got it's got
everything you want into like a a case
like that a true crime case so
uh yeah i've been that past couple days
if you will um we'll be back next week
with some more happy holidays
recommendations uh you know i i was yeah
i was i was someone who was like look
let's try and put some escapism joy
charm um i
am feeling great right now
but
it's a very very tough time and i like
i've had my ups and downs this past
period so hopefully you end this year on
an up note
uh get ready to hug your loved ones
get home for the holidays and hopefully
really enjoy ourselves amen man life is
about people and relationships so
tell someone you love them give them a
hug i'll give you a hug maybe i'll give
you a high five i've been staring at you
too long man
we did it another episode of forward
happy holidays guys see you next week
[Music]
you